for those of you saying Google camera is not available on vivo phones
What do you mean no main
You know you can't unpack the file.
Before everyone else said I could do a disposable bag string.
The vivo is definitely not like that.
I had to do it again just with an app
Now first of all I will be joining YouTube
If it's over
Just gonna search it up then give it a shot
If that's the case,
I've come up with some videos,
when you come out with some videos
im gonna start doing a video on the top of this but im gonna post it
When that video is coming
There's some disco francs underneath it,
right?
I'll press the moss there.
If you can press faint there is a link to download foot kick PC
going into it
When it comes to the link,
I'll download the file called M.
C. H. Point belly,
which is on the top
it's from YouTube when it's done then I'll be back in the video from now on
there's a convo file in it go to that convo file and then download it
I'll click on the little Google Wright in the link he's given here.
I'll join Google Wright.
I'll download the file that pops up there when it's done,
okay?
After downloading all that stuff
U just gotta do a camera app instead of a lighter
Instead I'll do it because the Google camera
app is back in the file and it's gone
also if it shows up in a normal download then i can
click on it and install it i think it's cool
Here I am going to do another one called M.
G. H.
cowboy belly
Then when it appears on here you press settings
I'll press the falling corpse foundation.
Then I'll press Install.
If that is.
Here comes the camera app,
I think it's cool
there going to do all the things he asked me to do
When it's over,
it's in the link up there.
press pan
Then go into setting.
going to gonfas.
at savage
Write dawg bagel and then
I'm going to press severe
Then I'll go back to Google
That's where the software for the bagpipes,
right?
Zach C bag HIV E.
I would download that software
now I'm just saying in the video there is no such thing as a deleted
it's just showing how you do it all step by step
I'll download any here.
If it's over,
here's a download
I'm gonna press annie far
Then the file here is already downloaded,
right?
After I download it,
I'll draw that thing in store
I'm just gonna join the mechanic
I'm gonna press the playing store
Then I'm gonna press insta,
right?
When you're done,
the app gets the inset
If that's the case
THATS NOT HOW YOU TELL PASSWORD
These tutorials also need to learn to take them away
Because it is
Look like that and then find yourself
These interviews are going up,
go away
Because if it isn't,
it takes peshawar from them
this every taking
Maybe it's some kind of weird thing to use
It's bad I'm sorry
Then I'll join the software now it's Zach Achie
I'll unwrap that cone file.
I'll press that confection.
Then I'll press the bag stingray.
Then
I'll beat you up,
Patrick Wald.
Ok press it
If that's the case,
the file is full,
right?
Out of that full file
tHiS tOoK mE tO mAkE yOu fAmOuS
I'll copy you
Go to the file and copy it,
it's easy, you know.
It's going to go to the download.
When it's done,
I'll press that convo named IPHERO
Then you copy those two
then it says same mode then press it
Then we're going into the internet store rave and then in the download
Um gypsy.
I'm gonna do the mode in the Hatchet Point belly.
If that's the case,
the glass has reached it,
right?
That's because it goes into the camera.
The glass has landed.
So you can take a camera then?
If it's for the carton of coffee oil
There's a little black box right next to where the camera shoots
I'm gonna have to double tap that box
From tapping like that.
The coffee will pop up
I won't tell you the password
I'm afraid you'll be asking passwords for a long time.
Just be yourself.
I said look out of the video
Bye bye everyone
You can also ask if it's not clear,
as far as I know,
I replied
I also know that some were skipped,
not deliberately skipped like a ho,
so I don't know how to answer,
so don't answer
It says answer if you know